a battle is waging at school boards
across the united states i'm sure we've
got hundreds of people out there that
would like to see those books before we
burn them
books deemed to be sowing division in
the classroom by republican-controlled
boards are being reviewed by authorities
some are being removed from the shelves
i don't know that any advocate who's
been working on
tracking or paying attention to the
freedom to read can recall a time when
the same book was removed or targeted
with such vitriol and haste in so many
places all over the country at once
and then the involvement of
politicians state legislatures governors
this is categorically different this is
next level we're gonna embrace our
parents not ignore them the issue was
key to the republicans retaking of the
governorship of virginia for the first
time in 11 years even after donald
trump's popularity had slumped there
last november this was one of the
adverts used by the victorious campaign
when my son showed me his reading
assignment my heart
sunk it was some of the most explicit
material you can imagine
she's referring to beloved by the nobel
prize-winning author tony morrison an
account of american slavery that does
contain some explicit scenes her son
would have been 17 or 18 at the time of
his assignment it's all part of a wider
cultural war against crt or critical
race theory an academic discipline using
law class and gender to analyze racism
in america contrary to the claims of
right-wing politicians though it is not
taught at school but at universities
but some argue that discussing race at
all either in the school classroom or
anywhere else is itself a form of racism
nobody wants this
crap okay this is an elite driven
phenomenon imbram x kendi's book stamped
was the second most targeted book for
banning in the us in 2020 according to
the american library association
he traces the current mood of censorship
to a backlash against the black lives
matter protests of 2020. you have more
people particularly more more white
americans seeking to understand the
history and the and and really the
presence of you know racism the history
of all the different groups that that
have formulated this country
then you had this
bitter attack to prevent people
from learning their history from
understanding their history from seeking
to understand how
it was that george floyd
was was murdered in such a brutal way
but the range of books being targeted go
way beyond those analyzing race in u.s
society the selection suggests hostility
to any consideration of gender sexual
identity reproductive rights or in this
case just a simple acknowledgement that
three african-american women were
crucial to nasa in the sixties
in fact many of the lists circulating of
objectional books have not originated
locally from concerned parents but have
been compiled by groups funded by
national republican party donors it's
pretty clear that one side of the
political spectrum believes is a winning
political issue
an issue that republicans hope will
mobilize the suburban white electorate
ahead of the upcoming midterm elections
shia britancy al jazeera washington